so i wanted to bring you on because i
think i saw i saw something on your
instagram a long time ago that was
something about modern moms like be a
traditional mom and then yeah this
little skit about being a traditional
mom which we can probably throw up on
the podcast yeah you can get an idea of
what it is ladies be good mothers this
summer and spend time with your children
the traditional way which doesn't
involve any of this because traditional
mothers were busy for most of human
history survival was a mom's full-time
job if your kids wanted chicken nuggets
it was up to you to take it from chicken
to nugget without refrigeration food had
to be cooked daily without indoor
plumbing getting water was a whole
ordeal the laundry spin cycle was your
bare hands and without electricity this
all had to be done during daylight hours
there is no historical precedent for
moms being the primary entertainers of
their kids they never had time
meaningful moments with their children
happen but it was in the midst of their
business or in the evenings maybe
traditional moms pinned clothes on
clotheslines and you pinned clothes on
pinterest either way it's natural and
normal for a woman to have a lot of her
daily focus on something other than
entertaining her kids hug your kids love
your kids tell your kids you're thrilled
to be doing life with them and then
unapologetically make time for your own
adult work because that is what
traditional motherhood looks like
but i just want to talk to you a bit
about just how you managed to first of
all you said six kids in eight years
yeah
that's that's crazy like
and that was
so did you stay home how did you manage
to do the writing at the same time or
was like for a period of time were you
just like just overrun with children or
no i i did i stayed home um i mean we
just couldn't afford full-time child
care for that number of kids you do end
up in a financial situation where it's
like one of us is staying home because
you get you know to get to get full-time
child care for that number of little
kids it's like a teacher oh yes daycare
yeah yeah it's it's no joke and so i did
stay home
and um but
i wrote
those books while i was staying home
with those kids at that time with a
bunch of little kids and people would
ask
how do you
do it like i mean how why would you add
more stress to your plate to have these
book deadlines and and i got a pretty
big deal with harper collins for my
second third books and that involved
deadlines and pressure
but what i always tell people is when
you find that thing
that you are called to do a friend of
mine calls it your blue flame when you
find that blue flame work that you're
meant to do
not only does it not feel like work but
it gives you energy i had more energy to
be a mom to i had three kids in diapers
for mo the better part of a decade three
kids in diapers at once because i have a
baby as soon as you know the older one
got out of diapers and so it you know
kids don't sleep through the night i
mean it was
it was very difficult physically
but what got me through it was doing
that writing having to do a chapter
having to have that that chapter
finished by friday it made me
get up a little earlier in the morning
it made me keep the kids on a schedule
so i could have that nap time to do my
writing and i i really believe that it i
was a better mom for the fact that i had
those writing deadlines during that time
okay okay that's interesting so i think
one of the things i struggled with when
i had scarlett
was
my mom was a stay-at-home mom um so it
was just my brother and i but she stayed
at home until i think we were in grade
seven and then she became a massage
therapist went to massage school like
full-time
but i had
i think what happened to me was i was in
university i had scarlet and then i
stayed
home
for a period of time like when she was
really really little and
i didn't
i felt guilty doing anything that didn't
have that seemed like it didn't have
anything to do with her so at that point
it was just like any type of writing or
like blog stuff i think i was just
writing a blog at that point or working
for my dad i was like
and i think it was partly
some people around me who are like
oh you should be only staying at home
and then there were the other people who
were like
you're wasting your life because you're
only staying at home but how do you like
do you have
suggestions or
anything for i guess mothers
who are trying to figure out how much
time they should be spending on
themselves when they have little kids
yeah and that's what you know you
mentioned that sketch i did about
traditional mothers and that was exactly
the point that i was making in that
sketch um so
to give you a little bit of background
to lead into my answer to what you just
asked so i had the benefit of uh i guess
it was about 15 years ago at this point
i interviewed some relatives of mine who
were born in around like 1910 1912 and
they were in their late 90s at the time
and i just asked them about life i
didn't even know what i was getting at
but we just we did some video we set up
the old heavy
camcorder and videoed this and at the
time i had just had a baby and so i
didn't
intend for these to be interviews about
motherhood but i was so stressed out
because my kid didn't sleep through the
night and and i just was really maxed
out about it so that's just where my
mind went and i ended up asking my
grandfather and then his his cousin and
some of these other people i talked to i
parenthood just kept coming up and one
of the things that was very clear to me
and keep in mind these people you know
they were in their 20s in the 1920s and
30s so they knew people as adults who
lived in the 1800s i mean they were
really connected to an old old way of
life
and one of the things they emphasized is
how busy mothers were i mean when you
think about it i've been joking about
this on my podcast
if your kids wanted chicken nuggets
any time before like the past 50 years
it was up to you to take it from chicken
to nugget that was all on you and think
about how time-consuming that is you're
slaughtering animals you're doing all
that stuff to dress them you're chopping
it up i mean this to just get dinner on
the table was an hours long process and
so when you look at the history of
humanity when you look at human
evolution it simply could not be the
case that human children have evolved to
need their mother's attention for all or
even 90 or even 80 of her waking hours
because the work of survival was very
very time consuming for our female
ancestors and that's the principle that
i've always used in my home of course
your kids need to be your priority and
they they need your attention and they
need focused attention but this is not
all day every day it couldn't be because
that's what i said in that in that
sketch that you saw traditional mothers
were busy and so if you are busy doing
your you're writing a book that's
similar to your ancestors who were busy
going slaughtering animals like getting
them ready for cooking yeah the work
you're doing is different but the time
commitment is about the same
okay that's interesting i guess some
people i think i think this was an
incorrect way of the way i was thinking
about it but it was because it didn't
have anything to do you know it was work
but it wasn't work for the kids so if
you're like trying to survive and
chopping wood and slaughtering chickens
then it's like okay that's directly for
the family but
i i know i certainly felt better when i
had time put aside for work because i'm
like i'm very you know work oriented
fulfills me you find a project to work
on and it's great right uh so
it was tricky though i definitely had a
hard time
being like no even though i'm doing
something that isn't related to that
it's okay yeah i was like deeply
ingrained in me as the wrong thing to do
yep and i think we all struggle with
that that there yeah of course there is
a question of okay i don't have to write
this book the way my great-grandmother
had to
wash the clothes because everyone only
had three pairs of clothes but to me it
it seems like
i don't think it matters as much to your
children
what
work you're doing i i think it just
feels natural that yeah mom has
stuff going on and for our ancestors
that might have been washing clothes out
on the washboard for us it might be
writing but i i don't think that it
that it matters to the children as long
as they know that
you
that they are your priority